>> Laura: NOW THE CLAIMS OF
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S THIRD ACCUSER,
JULIE SWETNICK, ARE SO
OUTLANDISH THAT WE WERE
SKEPTICAL FROM THE START.
THAT DOUBT SEEMS TO PRESSURE HAS
NUMEROUS OF STORIES FROM HER
PASTOR TRICKLE DOWN, ONE FROM
OUR NEXT GUEST, RICHARD
VINNECCY, THE EX-BOYFRIEND OF
SEVEN YEARS, CLAIMING SHE
THREATENED HIM AND HIS FAMILY.
WE ARE JOINED IN A TELEVISION
EXCLUSIVE BY MR. VINNECCY, ALONG
WITH HIS LAWYER, MR. HANSON.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
RICHARD, WHAT ARE YOUR
MOTIVATIONS FOR COMING FORWARD
NOW?
>> YES, THERE HAVE BEEN
POLITICAL ISSUES.
I WANT TO TELL THE TRUTH.
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I
CAME.
>> Laura: NOW, YOU CLAIM,
RICHARD, THAT MS. SWETNICK
THREATENED YOU AFTER YOU BROKE
UP WITH HER.
WHAT TYPES OF THREATS THREATS
ARE YOU ALLEGING?
>> SHE BASICALLY CALLED ME MANY
TIMES AND SAID YOU WILL NEVER,
EVER SEE YOUR UNBORN CHILD
ALIVE.
AND I'M JUST GOING TO GO OVER
THERE, I'M GOING TO KILL YOU
GUYS.
>> Laura: SHE SAID SHE WAS
GOING TO KILL YOU?
>> YES.
AND THAT HAS TOLD ME A LITTLE
BIT.
>> Laura: WELL, YOU TOLD
POLITICO ORIGINALLY, RICHARD,
THAT SHE THREATENED YOUR FAMILY
AND YOUR BABY.
>> CORRECT.
>> Laura: BUT YOU MENTALLY
UNBORN CHILD, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> I MEANT THE UNBORN CHILD.
I WAS NOT MARRIED AT THE TIME
WHEN THIS HAPPENED.
>> Laura: DID SHE EVER
DISCUSSED WITH YOU IN YOUR SEVEN
YEAR RELATIONSHIP, FROM
1994-2001, THE ISSUE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT, OR DID SHE
MENTION EVER HAVING BEEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED?
>> NEVER, NEVER ONCE SHE MENTION
THAT TO ME.
JUST TO TALK ABOUT EVERYTHING,
SHE NEVER ONCE MENTIONED THAT AT
ALL.
>> Laura: DID SHE HAVE A
POLITICAL BACKGROUND?
WAS SHE INTERESTED IN POLITICS?
>> NOT THAT I KNOW OF.
YOU KNOW, SHE WAS ALWAYS WANTING
TO BE THE CENTER OF ATTENTION.
SHE WAS ALWAYS TRYING TO IMPRESS
ME.
SHE WAS EXAGGERATING EVERYTHING.
IF ANYBODY KNOWS JULIE,
EVERYTHING THAT CAME OUT OF HER
MOUTH WAS JUST EXAGGERATIONS.
SHE NEVER MENTIONED THAT TO ME
AT ALL.
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT I WAS
VERY SURPRISED TO SEE.
I WAS VERY SURPRISED TO SEE HER
MAKING THESE ACCUSATIONS BECAUSE
SHE HAD NEVER, EVER MENTIONED
THAT TO ME AT ALL.
>> Laura: NOW, YOU FILED A
RESTRAINING ORDER IN MARCH OF
2001 AFTER THESE THREATS.
YOU SAID IN REPEATED PHONE CALLS
TO YOU, THREATENING YOU, AND
YOUR UNBORN CHILD AND YOUR
FAMILY.
BUT YOU NEVER FOLLOW THROUGH
WITH IT.
YOU NEVER APPEARED IN COURT.
IF YOU WERE SO THREATENED BY
JULIE SWETNICK, YOUR
EX-GIRLFRIEND, THEN WHY DIDN'T
YOU FOLLOW THROUGH?
>> THAT IS A QUESTION THAT
EVERYBODY IS ASKING.
THE REASON I DIDN'T WAS BECAUSE
I KNEW THAT I WOULD HAVE TO SEE
HER AGAIN.
I TALKED AT THAT TIME TO MY
FAMILY, AND WE DECIDED NOT TO DO
ANYTHING.
NOT TO FOLLOW THROUGH.
I AM NOT THE TYPE OF PERSON, I
KNEW THE TYPE OF PERSON JULIE
IS, AND I WAS AFRAID, TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU.
SO I JUST DECIDED TO LEAVE IT
ALONE.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD GO AWAY
BECAUSE AT THAT TIME, THE ONLY
THING I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT WAS
MY FAMILY.
WE CHANGED OUR NUMBERS AND
MOVED, AND THAT IS BASICALLY
WHAT WE DID.
AND WE NEVER HEARD FROM HER
AGAIN.
>> AND AFTER YOU CAME FORWARD
AND THAT INITIAL INTERVIEW WITH
POLITICO, DID YOU HEAR FROM ANY
OF HER REPRESENTATIVES?
OR DID YOU HEAR FROM HER AT ALL?
>> NOT AT ALL.
NOT AT ALL.
>> Laura: YOUR OWN CREDIBILITY
HAS BEEN CALLED INTO QUESTION,
AND I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS, BY HER
LAWYER, MICHAEL AVENATTI.
HE APPEARED EARLIER TONIGHT ON
CNN.
LET'S WATCH.
>> HER BOYFRIEND SAYS SHE CAN'T
BE TRUSTED, THAT IT'S A
CREDIBILITY THING.
SWETNICK CAN'T BE TRUSTED.
IS THIS A THREAT TO YOU?
>> NO, IT'S LUDICROUS, CHRIS,
FIRST OF ALL.
ONE LAWSUIT WAS FILED.
IT WAS ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
DISMISSED.
THE CLAIMS BY HER EX-BOYFRIEND,
I MEAN WHO DOESN'T HAVE AN
EX-BOYFRIEND OR AN EX-GIRLFRIEND
WHO MIGHT SAY BAD THINGS ABOUT
THEM?
>> Laura: WELL, AND
EX-BOYFRIEND, YOU KNOW.
IF BREAKUPS ARE BRUTAL, RIGHT?
THEY CAN BE BRUTAL.
IN YOUR CASE, IT WAS REALLY NOT
FUN.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SAY YOU
DON'T LIKE HER BECAUSE YOU WERE
WITH HER FOR SEVEN YEARS AND
THAT IT ABOUT ENDING.
>> YEAH, THAT'S A -- LIKE I SAY
BEFORE, IF ANYBODY KNOWS THE
JULIE SWETNICK I KNOW, IF YOU
ASKED ME PERSONALLY IF I BELIEVE
HER, I DON'T BELIEVE HER.
PERSONALLY, I DON'T BELIEVE HER.
I REALLY DON'T BELIEVE HER.
NOBODY KNOWS JULIE SWETNICK
BETTER THAN ME.
AND THE FACTS ARE THAT I KNOW
HER.
THAT IS WHY I CAME HERE TO TELL
THE TRUTH.
I KNOW HOW SHE IS.
>> Laura: WELL, YOU WERE WITH
HER FOR SEVEN YEARS.
YOU ARE DESCRIBING HER LIKE SHE
IS A TOTAL NIGHTMARE, BUT HE
SPENT SEVEN YEARS WITH HER.
>> FOR THE FIRST COUPLE OF
YEARS, WE HAD A NICE
RELATIONSHIP.
WE WEREN'T TOGETHER FOR SEVEN
YEARS.
WE WERE TOGETHER OFF AND ON FOR
SEVEN YEARS.
THE FIRST COUPLE OF YEARS, ABOUT
A YEAR AND A HALF, AND THEN
ANOTHER COUPLE OF YEARS WE WERE
IN BETHESDA.
IT THEN TRANSFERRED TO PANAMA.
I CAME BACK A COUPLE OF YEARS
LATER.
WE WERE SEEING EACH OTHER ONCE
IN A WHILE.
BUT THE MORE I SAW HER, THE MORE
I SAW HER, I BASICALLY
EXPERIENCED WHAT SHE WAS DOING.
I JUST DIDN'T LIKE IT, AND THE
FACT THAT SHE WAS LYING TO ME,
SHE PRETTY MUCH TALKED ABOUT
EVERYBODY.
SHE TALKED ABOUT LAWSUITS.
SHE WAS TRYING TO -- AT
ONE POINT, I REMEMBER SHE TOLD
ME THAT SHE WAS FILING A
LAWSUIT, HARASSMENT LAWSUIT
AGAINST AMERICAN AIRLINES.
I SAID YOU WERE GOING TO HAVE TO
STOP THIS LAWSUIT THING BECAUSE
IT IS RIDICULOUS.
SHE WOULD TALK TO ME ABOUT HER
FAMILY.
SHE WOULD -- EVERY TIME WE WOULD
GET INTO A FIGHT, SHE WOULD GET
RIGHT IN MY FACE.
SHE WOULD ASK ME TO HIT HER.
I MEAN, THAT'S JUST REALLY
WEIRD.
MOST OF MY FRIENDS DID NOT LIKE
HER.
IN FACT, I CAN TESTIFY ABOUT
THAT.
>> Laura: HOLD ON, RICHARD.
HOLD ON.
SHE WAS LIKE "HIT ME?"
WHY WOULD SHE SAY THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
FOR ANY MINOR ISSUES THAT WE HA
HAD, SHE WOULD ALWAYS GET INTO
MY FACE.
THE FIRST TIME, IT WAS LIKE OH,
MY GOD.
THIS IS INCREDIBLE.
SHE WOULD GET RIGHT IN MY FACE.
SHE WOULD SAY "HIT ME."
HIT ME, RICHARD.
SHE WOULD SAY REMEMBER WHAT
HAPPENED TO MY EX-BOYFRIEND.
I WOULD JUST WALK AWAY.
IT WAS JUST IMPOSSIBLE TO ME.
>> Laura: RICHARD, RICHARD.
I KNOW YOU'VE HAD SOME FINANCIAL
ISSUES IN THE PAST, AND YOU
HAVEN'T SHIED AWAY FROM THAT,
CORRECT?
YOU'VE BEEN UNDERWATER ON A
MORTGAGE, YOU'VE HAD YOUR OWN
ISSUES.
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU WATCHED HER
TESTIFY LAST WEEK, WHEN SHE WENT
THROUGH THE VERY HEARTFELT
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT HAPPENED TO
HER AT THE HANDS OF WHAT SHE
SAID WAS BRETT KAVANAUGH, WAS
WENT THROUGH YOUR MIND?
WHEN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY WAS
THINK SHE SO CREDIBLE, SHE SO
BELIEVABLE, YOU KNEW HER FOR
SEVEN YEARS.
WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH YOUR
MIND?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, WHEN I
FIRST HEARD HER, HER NAME
MENTIONED ON TV, I'M THINKING
OH, MY GOD, .
>> Laura: SHE OBVIOUSLY
DIDN'T -- EXCUSE ME, REFREEZE.
SHE DIDN'T TESTIFY.
WHEN YOU HEARD HER COME UP WITH
THESE ALLEGATIONS -- THE HIDEOUS
ATTACK IT, A GANG RAPE, A
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
YOU HAVE BEEN WITH HER FOR SEVEN
YEARS.
DID SHE EVER SAY ANYTHING ABOUT
GANG RAPE?
>> NEVER.
NEVER.
WE TALKED ABOUT EVERYTHING.
SHE NEVER ONCE MENTIONED THIS TO
ME AT ALL.
>> Laura: RICHARD, MARSIA,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US TONIGHT.